So all three people that Lauren just mentioned are considered by society to be
very intelligent people. The truth is, we don't really know their intelligence.
They never took IQ tests. In fact, there's reason to believe that Darwin for
example, was only average in his IQ. But these people still accomplished great
things. So what's going on here is that psychologists, when they use the word
intelligent. They mean something much more specific than the way people use the
term in every day life. So what did all three of these people have in common?
They were all very creative. They were able to generate new ideas in new fields
of study. So psychologists make a distinction between creativity and
intelligence. So we do this because they're really different things. So the
research on the relationship between intelligence and creativity has shown that
the correlation is only about 0.20 between them. Meaning that knowing someone's
IQ only tell us a very little bit about their level of creativity. So for
instance, someone could be really high on intelligence and not all that
creative. Likewise, someone could be really creative and not score all that
high on IQ. Although they probably would be at least average or maybe slightly
above average on intelligence.